as every third thing piece will tell you
we are a fractured country and when it
comes to guns the debate is as heated as
ever
thankfully On June 11th on Comedy
Central I Jordan Klepper solve guns
through an ingenious strategy of rubbing
elbows embedded with a militia driving
race cars and shooting big-ass weapons
til a bit of sanity returns to our
country Murph
in order to keep saying myth just a
little over a week ago our nation's gun
divide was on full display in Atlanta
where the NRA held its National
Convention a perfect place for me to
selflessly reach across the partisan
line and get NRA members pumped to watch
my special who doesn't like common sense
approaches to gun violence you're
proposing the gun show loophole right
yes smart guy so what is it that brings
80,000 Gunners to Atlanta it's just fun
to look at all the all the stuff and see
the people that you've seen in magazines
and in on television this is like
comic-con but for death because I'll
just have to take your word for it and
go what are the fanboys excited about
this year it's kind of cool to walk
around and see all the new products to
come out and the new ammo and stuff like
that it's 2017 is gonna be a good year
for gun oh yeah what was your favorite
shooting of 2016 2016 honestly um plug
things like Shane Cole we and those guys
I met Lilly Denver or no it was out in
Utah actually they had a big Utah at a
mall or no what do you mean where was
the shooting it was that it wasn't like
a shooting like that cool no it was a
like like a tournament you know like oh
I'm doing a special where I claim to
solve guns it's all gonna be all vain
guns and solving guns have to do with
were you gonna have to watch
June 11th to the Levin on Comedy Central
from Comedy Central I just hope it's my
comedy that's me doesn't solve problems
Jordan Klepper solves problems about
guns on June 11
I'm not getting through it's time to
become a sheep in wolf's clothing and
give these people what they want guns
and witty teachers
[Music]
we like butter gun stats on June 11th
because children a gun all right whoa
whoa unfortunately common sense isn't
one size fits all
if t-shirts weren't going to solve it I
would have to solve it on Sunday June
11th